this [__] thing man I can't remember
how I saw it somebody sent it to me Lord
tonight first of all black preacher and
he said
L um said
L do you believe the
Lord there's a d he doesn't give a [__]
why would
he um is a preacher preachers don't give
a [__] you know what I'm talking about
they do everything for the Lord and have
a jet these these television and they're
they're just like give money to the
homeless in their
jet um this is this is from silly funny
videos okay you know try
harder silly funny videos try harder
with the account name anyway um young
gay man man is delivered from
homosexuality and party dances oh so
foreign party dancing dancing is fine
anyway um do you guys party dancing or
what tonight you guys party dancing
tonight or you just
um so this
[__] do you believe that the Lord
tonight has set you free yes
sir okay do you believe that the Lord
tonight is has set you free and then the
guy just goes without hesitation which
is what I [__] love about this [__]
he just says yes sir dude there is no
second guessing and that is because the
preacher knows how to talk and knows his
[__] this preacher is The
Mentalist this preacher tells you how to
feel and the dude is just like yes sir I
I don't have a mind no more so I ain't
got no M no more
so shoot from the hip
so he just
goes do you believe the Lord has set you
and on the back end of him talking yes
sir nodded so hard his head almost
lopped off now we
continue and tell those people now turn
around and tell those people and this is
the best cuz the guy goes to grab the
microphone and then the preacher has
something else to say and the guy goes
to grab the microphone and
misses a [__] and
um
I'm not so
oh oh wow he grabs the microphone phone
the first thing he does
is so good
dude I used to have a Spanish teacher
that was named Mr teame and he would he
would Breathe so much it was
unbelievable it was like dude how many
[__] lungs do you have he would just
be like hello
Muchachos who got L
baseball not gay no more oh dude this is
the best right here well let's start it
over because you really got to ramp it
up when you ramp it up there's a big pay
payoff D it so he just turn around and
tell those
people tell them I also so not specific
dude turn around and tell those people
tell them and the guy just grabs a
microphone literally could have said
anything um I am
sand so
uh
I'm not gay no
more delivered oh I'm not gay no more I
am deliver it wow dude he just the
enthusiasm he
goes I'm not gay no more I am delivered
and he says
delivered the Lord delivered
him wow that is just
I'm not gay no more I am delivered wow
he felt it dude I love when people feel
lies I love when a guy gets fired and
says oh this the best thing that ever
happened to
me going to start a new
life
delivered eyes rolled back in his head
when he said
it I'm not gay no more I am delivered
cool let's keep going I don't like me no
oh screaming it dude I am
delivered I don't like men no more oh my
god
[Laughter]
dude I don't like mans no
more lost
credibility when you made men even more
plural I don't like mans no more it
looked like he felt himself so hard that
he I'm shocked he didn't do this
afterwards this guy wants to believe it
so badly that he's yelling it so hard
the it I don't like men no more I said I
like women wow I don't like men no
didn't say it didn't say it and then he
says I said I like
women and as he's saying
it he turns around and faces the
back
lying
hey you turned around
and faced the
back you're
lying hello officer why did you pull me
over do you not know why do you know how
fast you were
going no honestly I have no
idea why' you turn around oh I'm
lying
I mean dude he turned around that's the
best also guess if he's wearing a bow
tie or not oh you guessed
right guess if he's got a Paisley Blazer
on you guessed
right oh wow dude I did not know he did
that I don't think I watched this whole
thing I actually don't even know if
I like women women wom
wom wow possessed possessed possessed
[Laughter]
underwater women women women
women put his face in titties you know
um so anyway motorboating
um I'm not screaming screaming so loud
has a microphone the guys on stage with
him are just like I don't uh we thought
we thought this was we thought he was
paralyzed and we were going to help him
stand I would not date a man tell
himself I would not te a Pur I not put
on makeup himself I will I will love a
woman so so not sure what he is going to
say dude also went way further into it
like talking about how he's not gay and
then immediately we got a hint that he
also dresses like a woman you
know I will not carry a purse I will not
put on
makeup oh okay that's fine dude that's
all
good and then he says I will love a
women like he's one of those [__]
Saudi Arabian guys that comment on on
Instagram girls
pictures picture of Bob's
please
um I will love a woman wow so not
everybody's going to say now listen what
y'all praise God with him hold on wait a
minute somebody believe God you know
what's [__] it's funny but it's also
like here's the thing I think two years
ago I would have just thought this was
funny
but just because like I'm I'm like
really trying to like understand
myself like everybody's got their [__]
you know everybody's got their [__] that
they're that they're that they're trying
to [__] work through and it just it
just is sad that this guy thinks that
he it's sad to me this video because
like dude if he's gay [__] be gay and
let's just chill man you don't have to
like a
women you know you don't have to have
the [__] L delivered
you just [__] be gay be so gay dude
put on makeup wear a purse Rock that
[__] you
know let's see the
comments someone writes I said I like
women's women's women's women's blah
BL
wow I mean dude it's just uh
well
I hope that that dude is just out
there living with a guy and loving it